皆さんこんにちは
リンクしてよくいらっしゃいました
ダニングエストは何でしょうか
TheEnglishtoyouWeb
サイトは言葉の勉強のいろんな材料と
そして言葉の勉強のためのコツですねどう
すればうまく外国語を勉強できるかと
いろんなまあ
秘密がこちらに書いてあります私が誰でも
たくさんの外国語を話せることができると
思いますそして世界中もっとたくさんの人
がもっとたくさんの外国語を話せるんで
あれば世界がもっと良い
地球になると思いますそう思ってます
自分が
各国語を勉強した家庭においてどうすれば
うまく早く
楽しく勉強できるかっていうのはだいたい
わかってきました
そこで第一に
複雑な文法を一生懸命勉強してもそれが
それほどまあ効果はないそれよりも
楽しく
楽しく好きな内容をたくさん聞いて
読んでそして重点を5
位それは単語とフレーズそれにまあ
絨毯を置けばもっともっと勉強
過程も楽しくなるしもっと早くもう進歩
できると思いますそのためにこの
リングイリストドットコムというサイトも
こちらでこちらいろんなこの言葉で
いろんな眉がありますからどうぞ
ゆっくりこちら見てください我々の図書館
よく見てくださいそれからですね
効果的に
単語とフレーズを勉強するにはやはり
システムが必要なんですよそこではうちの
関連ウェブサイトでリンク
の方へも
尋ねてみてください
そこでは
合意いわゆる単語とフレーズを勉強する
ためのいろんな機能が
揃ってますそして勉強する過程は全部我々
はもうはっきりを剥離しますから統計が出
ますのでそうしますと自分のレベルにあっ
た内容を選ぶことがもっとやりやすくなり
ます自分が好きなものを選ぶとこの勉強が
楽しくなるもちろんたくさん聞いたりこの
言葉にだんだん
慣れてくるとそして単語も増えてくると
ですねやはり話したいと自分が表現したい
と書きたいということになりますから
そしてリンクでもですねやはりうまく
勉強した言葉を
書くときにでも話す時にでも使えるように
あるいは話した時にあれが書いた時に時々
使い方がちょっと
間違えましたとそういうところもですね
うまく
間違って使ったその単語をですねもう一度
リンクシステムに取り入れてまた勉強する
というような
システムもあるもんですからそしてもう一
つはやはりリンクはです一つの
コミュニティなんですよ世界中のいろんな
国いろんな文化の人がメンバーなんですよ
会員なんですよそのメンバーがまた自分の
母国語で
素晴らしい面白い内容自分の生活から自分
の考え方からですねまあ書いたりあるいは
録音したりしてこれは全会員の全
コミュニティのメンバーにですねまた貢献
してるわけですだからダリングとも
あるいはリンクも非常に
楽しい言葉の勉強の場なんですよだから
ぜひこちらドリンクしてごゆっくり見て
くださいそして時間があったら
リンクの方へも行ってそこで無料登録も
できますので
楽しく言葉を勉強しましょう
リングスになってくださいじゃさようなら